hi I'm Ben Zorn and I'm going to be
talking about spreadsheet understanding
including two projects Jura and
excellent which is joint work with Alex
philosoph Emory Berger and Dan Berrigan
so the thing about spreadsheets is that
they're used by millions of people
they're used to make important decisions
like financial decisions economic
decisions etc and many of these
spreadsheets actually have errors and in
fact what we see if you look at the the
news the Reinhardt Rogov spreadsheet
which is which is a spreadsheet
developed by Harvard economists was used
to justify a policy of austerity
including in countries like Greece and
in the United States the Reinhart Rogoff
spreadsheet is a very complex
spreadsheet that involves looking at the
history of debt in countries over a
period of hundreds of years and what we
find with the O'Brien harborough
spreadsheet is that actually had
actually important errors that led the
authors to draw the wrong conclusions so
the the key message in this is that
spreadsheets are used by many people to
make important decisions and what we're
trying to do is bring tools to the
spreadsheet users to help them
understand their spreadsheets more
easily and help them make better
decisions based on them so let me start
with our first tool which is called
excellent and what I'm showing here is
actually the Reinhart Rogoff spreadsheet
which was originally developed by his
Harvard economist and in particular the
important sheet here is a summary sheet
which evolves as you see on the on the
in the rows a number of countries US UK
etc 27 different country are 24
different countries and information
about the historical debt of
indebtedness of these countries related
to their their a great economic growth
and if you look at the spreadsheet it
looks very complicated you know in each
of these countries if you break it out
like the US has much data many rows of
data for many years starting 1791 in the
United States and but if you look at the
summary you can imagine why it would be
hard as a user of this spreadsheet to
understand what you know whether it's
correct or not and so one of the things
we've done in our technology we have a
technology called excellent which allows
us to very quickly understand the
structure of the spreadsheet using
statistics
so in particular if I just press this
button reveal structure on the Reinhardt
Rogov spreadsheet the colors are going
to encode information to the user about
the things that are happening on the
spreadsheet in particular the gray means
that I have data just regular data but
the gray means is being referenced by
some formula in the sheet the yellow is
unusual because the yellow means it's a
data that's on the sheet that is not
being referenced by a formula and what
we see immediately if in this
presentation is that this range of data
is not being used by any formula and
what if you look if you'll drill down
more closely what you find is that the
formula here which is computing it
average actually fails to include this
range of cells in the average and this
is the bug in them in the Reinhardt
Rogov spreadsheet in particular the the
countries Canada Belgium Austria and
Australia are not being counted in the
average and in fact that leads them to
an incorrect conclusion so what we have
with excellent is a tool that allows you
to very quickly understand what's going
on in the spreadsheet and make important
decisions and as you can imagine you
know the individuals who created the
spreadsheet and originally Brian era
Rogoff if they had had this tool they
wouldn't have made this a very important
error which led to incorrect conclusions
so the we can also look at particular
sub other sheets in the spreadsheet for
example in the United States if you say
reveal structure on this one you see
different colors again showing that
different different columns are being
computed different ways but one thing
that's interesting is we have here
essentially what we call a
suspiciousness index that tells you that
this particular range of cells and if I
click on it it will take me there this
range of cells is suspicious and in
particular what you see here is that
this cell the very first cell k7 is
actually being computed by a different
formula and then the cells below it so
again very quickly we can find a bug in
the spreadsheet and which again this is
the original spreadsheet so the authors
did not actually understand okay so
that's excellent I encourage you to try
it out it is actually available online
here's another technology
so one of the things that we're trying
to do in our research is to understand
spreadsheets because they contain both
data formulas and which is code and
presentation things like what a human is
trying to communicate to another human
so this sheet in particular is an
example of this the user has headers the
user is formatted the data in such a way
that they're of their blank rows and
columns to help with whitespace and as a
result where this this table starts and
ends is actually not completely obvious
it's not explicit in the in the
presentation so what we've developed is
a technology called Jura which is
essentially trying to find the the
tables in a given sheet which is
basically an arbitrary bounding so Jura
uses a technology based on neural
networks that looks at every cell and
ask the question the neural net were
asked the question is the cell the
corner of a table and so what we have is
we have an ability to show what the
neural network thinks about about the
corners and what we're seeing here is
that the neural network is saying this
corner this corner and this corner all
look like bottom bottom right corners
right that's what the blue encodes this
corner up here looks like a top left
corner so what it's trying to do is
understand though the overall structure
of the sheet based on individual cells
and what it thinks are the corners once
it understands the whole like a holistic
view of all the cells our technology
Jurek and then basically find the table
and so because they find show me all the
tables on the sheet and what we see here
now is it understands that this is the
table note for example that this
particular part of the table which is
just an annotation is not counted by
jurors part of the table which makes
sense because it's really not it's more
money it's more like a footnote so what
we shown here is two different
technologies using two different
techniques the statistical analysis and
neural networks to help us understand
spreadsheets and ultimately are going to
empower users to quickly and effectively
make use of their spreadsheets and get
in and come to correct conclusions thank
you for your time